MAX SALTONSTALL:
The city of Memphis
has been frustrated by
potholes in its streets,
especially as they pop up
during the winter freezes.
Wet weather plus regular
traffic make it hard to keep up.
Potholes make driving less safe,
damage vehicles on the road,
and slow down traffic.
I'm Max Saltonstall.
And today, we'll
explore how Memphis,
with some help from
SpringML Google Cloud,
came up with an
automated scalable system
to help them combat
their pothole problem.
In one year, Memphis repaired
over 63,000 potholes.
So we're talking
about a ton of work
and a huge effort
required to locate them
throughout the city.
To help scale up and
improve efficiency,
the city could use
data they already have.
The city buses in Memphis
all have video cameras,
though this rich source of data
wasn't being used as a source
for detecting potholes.
Many cities already have an
assortment of connected devices
and data being collected.
So there are problematic
potholes in Memphis
and the need for a better
way to identify them escape.
If they could collect
video from the buses,
detect potholes, somehow
integrate GPS data to locate it
in space, and then integrate
with city information
service systems, such as
311, to dispatch crews,
but how are they going to do it?
Machine learning.
The city of Memphis
worked with SpringML
to develop a model with Google
Cloud's Video Intelligence API
that could check the
video footage each night
and store results in Google
Cloud Storage and BigQuery.
Then, they made a web
UI for the 311 operators
to view images and
evaluate the results,
deciding on priority for
dispatching the repair crews.
Take a look at what it can do.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
The new system
allowed the city teams
to take action quickly and
address the newly detected road
issues within 48 hours.
Now Memphis has safer
roads with fewer potholes,
more efficient employees,
lower insurance claims,
and a modern approach
to service delivery.
Automated pothole detection
is just one example
of cities using their data
to augment city services
and improve
government efficiency,
with the help of cloud
infrastructure and Video
Intelligence solutions.
Thanks for joining me.
For more information about
SpringML and the Google Cloud
Video Intelligence API,
check out the links below.
[MUSIC FADING OUT]